I did my internship in the press office
and today I am a press officer in the
county press office so I have done a
full round about ten years later I got
hired in the place where I did my
internship I think the traineeship helps
very much to get in touch with real life
when you were at school if University
you are in a specific environment
academic and it's not so real when
you're in the real life and as it was in
the country press office it real
deadlines and you have to be hit the
news and otherwise it's too late and
it's not worth doing it the most
important thing I did during the
internship was or most important most
interesting and most fun was to follow
the European Council you get to see the
leaders clothes you get to see things
that you have only seen on TV it was a
privilege like that and I think that
gives a lot of motivation I think it
gave me motivation to finish my studies
and to go into a certain part what was
the most the most important thing that I
learned was probably to work hard and
work fast of course working for the
council now I must say this is the most
important place this is where the real
decisions are made this is where the
heads of states are this is where Obama
comes to visit
you